and finally new rule if even
dead people hate you you got to ask am i
doing something wrong
you know the only bipartisan agreement
we seem to have these days is that
neither party wants donald trump at
their funerals
john mccain barbara bush
elijah cummings john dingle and
now john lewis all their families felt
the same way
our loved one is dead don't ruin it
trump is about as welcome at a funeral
as the gypsy woman who wanders into
restaurants and sells you roses at a
business dinner
and he's the president and people still
don't want him there
it's like a children's hospital turning
down batman
what kind of spectacular prick do you
have to be that everyone's last request
is
make sure that [ __ ] isn't at my
funeral
you know i watched the eulogies last
week for john lewis and was struck by
the genuine
outpouring from everyone who ever
encountered this
model of a man and i thought of trump
and actually felt
sad for him because at his funeral
no one will ever talk about him like
that
then i thought maybe if trump could hear
what a eulogy for him would sound like
maybe that would give him some insight
into himself
so i've prepared a most example now
let me be clear so the secret service
feels
no need to visit i wish donald trump a
long
healthy life some place where he can't
harm america
and i have only condemnation for anyone
who would ever wish
any president no matter how much you
dislike them any physical harm
but in the adventures of tom sawyer
when tom and huckleberry finn get to
attend their own funeral
they learn a lot about themselves so in
that spirit
let us imagine ourselves many years in
the future
and listening to these soothing words
[Music]
dear family and frenemies of donald
trump
some men look at the world and ask why
donald trump looked at the world and
asked what's in it for me
his generosity knew only limits
and he never once failed to put himself
before others
he was a devoted father who every day
tried to teach his children the wrong
lessons of life
be quick to anger never let go of a
grudge
see the worst in people and treat them
all
equally based strictly on how much money
they make and what they look like
so many wanted to speak here today but
couldn't break their non-disclosure
agreements
and our hearts go out to melania who
rsvp'd maybe
donald always said he knew she was the
one the moment he saw her and said those
three little words
add to cart
donald loved so many things
money golf lawsuits
porn stars dictators organized crime and
the 35 percent of the american people
who still like him
the other 65 could go [ __ ] themselves
he once said that the experience of
not being in vietnam taught him the most
important lesson of all
that there's no problem so big you can't
lie your way out of it
and when it came to flouting the law he
was a criminal's criminal
and intellectually a [ __ ] among giants
a man of few words about a hundred
mostly tremendous disgusting strongly
and [ __ ]
[Music]
donald trump never met a man he liked
and yet he always suffered fools you
could tell him
anything and he'd believe it it's
painful to think he could still be with
us if only his personal physician wasn't
that lady who believed medicine came
from outer space
donald's greatest hero winston churchill
said of his own mortality
i'm ready to meet my maker whether my
maker is prepared for the great ordeal
of meeting me
is another matter well god
trump's your problem now as for me
personally
i i guess what i'll miss most about don
is
his dull wit he was never laughing
and when he made you laugh it was always
unintentional
but as a walking parody of himself he
was a challenge to satirize and made me
a better comedian for it
[Music]
he died as he lived
wearing makeup and lying in front of all
of us
so fly free whiny little [ __ ]
fly free may you find the piece your
twitter thumbs
never could
you